vingt-deux jours après le début de cette
campagne
ils sont en route vers leur premier
débat une occasion pour les quatre chefs
de croiser le fer en français devant un
électeur a clairement disposé à écouter
les discussions vont se faire sur trois
thèmes les grands enjeux sociaux ont été
abordée d'entrée de jeu avortement
mourir dans la dignité
le chef conservateur se retrouve
rapidement dans la meilleure de ses
adversaires toi en bouche il est ce que
vous croyez qu'une femme devrait avoir
le choix
alors vous le savez très bien que quand
j'étais j'utilise toujours ouvert avec
ma position je suis pour le mariage même
sexe je suis pour la mourir de la droit
de mourir dans la dignité
est ce que vous êtes prêt de dire ça
aujourd'hui le fédéral devrait-il
respecter la décision des tribunaux
québécois d'élargir l'accès à l'aide
médicale à mourir
nous allons réviser la loi en dents de
scie mois nous allons pas aller en appel
le chef du bloc québécois devient
rapidement la cible des attaques dans
dossier de la laïcité au québec accusé
de semer la division chicane comme ça
les gens d'accord son sigle les gens
veulent d'urbanisme c'est exactement ce
que monsieur blanchet en nettement c'est
exactement ce que vous faites vous
essayez toujours dé créer des chicanes
avec aussi le débat des niqab
vous aurez aussi essayer de créer des
chicanes
c'est en fait c'est dégueulasse ce
trouble est ainsi toujours des critiques
en l'absence d'un de chira la marche sur
le climat est rapidement souligné
tout comme les lacunes perçu dans son
plan environnemental et son projet de
corridor énergétique
je crois que c'est meilleur pour la
planète si le canada pour réduire les
émissions dans un contexte global et je
crois que nos standards ici aucun sont
plus avec les autres pays où on doit un
protêt climat de terreur et ça c'est
vous allez aussi un cousin péri sur le
québec avec une croix il ne pouvait pas
cacher ça vous allez
imposez vous voulez imposer un pipeline
à l'écran une cro chef conservateur
dirige sa riposte vers justin trudeau le
ton et acrimonieux l'attaquent et
personnel hockey canadien qui pense
qu'il devient plus riche qu'on paie une
nouveauté axe et vous êtes un petit peu
près dix jours la création d'un virement
et à ce moment un chef ici ce soir qu'il
ya deux avions pour son grand père à
accra le sort de snc-lavalin et la
contreverse que toute la sphère à
alimenter permettent au chef du bloc
québécois de faire contraste avec la
position de ses adversaires y'a pas de
bandits qui travaille chez snc lavalin
parce qu'il ya eu une maladresse grave
de monsieur trudeau et une volonté de
monsieur scheer de jouer contre le
québec pour faire des gains dans le
reste du canada
la défense des intérêts québécois
devient l'occasion pour justin trudeau
de rappeler l'impact des coupes
conservatrices en ontario et on va
s'assurer que partout au canada ont soit
atteindre défendre la langue française
défendre les valeurs qui nous sont
chères en a toujours d'accord que le
traitement que les québécois accordent à
leur minorité anglophone devrait être
équivalent sur l'ensemble du territoire
canadien oublier prochain rendez vous
lundi en anglais et judy en français et
si daniel thibault radio canada montréal